It's a
girlfriend who
says that men are idiots I paid her to go on a date
You should know that's all there
is to it When I see a cute girl like you
I always like men,
don't I? No, I don't mean that I like men,
ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, it's
definitely childish  But if you look at it from the other side, you're a romantic It
's
hard to live realistically, but it's probably more difficult to have a dream in the middle
[music]
I wish I had a girlfriend like Mr. Cheese It
would be soothing and rosy
Kazuya No
matter where I went, people envy me The next door always smells like heaven You can't laugh
at the court  Give me rice every day, hold my hand and let me x
until I get tired
[music] I want her after all [music]
I
want
her